president Trump introduced his new tax
plan today I know you're all excited
about it that was a really great real
that's what happens when like an air
mattress deflate no president Trump says
his new tax plan would greatly simplify
the US tax code it's gonna simplify it
yeah it would divide everyone into two
brackets taxpayers and President Trump
that's basically why it's very simple
you have very simple you all know an
extremely extremely conservative
Republican one the Alabama primary this
guy's very conservative the winner of
the Alabama Senate primary ray Moore
once equated homosexuality to having sex
with a cow yeah Mora went on to say
however I also have some criticisms of
it
[Laughter]
thank you for that yeah there are rumors
that NFL legend Peyton Manning may run
for Senate Peyton Manning could run for
Senate yeah yeah sure why not experts
say there's no way that mixing the NFL
and politics could possibly go wrong
it's been reported that morale is very
low among the Taliban their morale is
low yeah yeah you know things are bad
when suicide bombers are too depressed
to go to work that's a bad day you're
like what's the point
that's Krauts funny tonight I said this
there's really depressed and they was
like oh that's too bad
Khloe Kardashian is reportedly pregnant
[Applause]
yeah Chloe said she doesn't care if it's
a boy or a girl just as long as it has
over 1 million Instagram followers
[Applause]
you